[Musique]
mais bon
niché au coeur de la vallée du rift ce
parc s'appelle ale jet la porte de
l'enfer
connu pour ses falaises et pour ces
animaux sauvages qui vivent ici
mais aussi et surtout pour ces
mystérieuses roche fumantes que l'on
trouve un peu partout
ce sont des vapeurs naturel que
christine katana observe et analyse
chaque jour la géologue on connaît tous
les secrets
des stingers tomates la vapeur ici est
vraiment très chaude quelque chose
autour de 120 degrés c'est brûlant et
tout ça vient de réservoirs d'eau qui se
trouve à environ 1000 mètres de
profondeur un âne ici dans la vallée du
rift on a beaucoup d'activités
volcaniques
le sol est très fracturé la chaleur se
faufile et remonte par là au kenya on
considère cette chaleur comme un trésor
à un cadeau de la planète car elle peut
être utilisée pour produire de
l'électricité
c'est l'énergie géothermique la seconde
ressource la plus abondante sur terre
après l'énergie solaire une ressource
encore largement inexploitées le procédé
est assez simple dépuis géant recueille
la vapeur et l'acheminer vers les
centrales électriques
la vapeur arrive des puits d'extraction
et passent par ce réseau de gros tuyaux
cyrus karine dit y est l'un des
pionniers de la géothermie au kenya il
est ingénieur dont la centrale d'olkaria
depuis 34 ans il ya ici cinq centrales
en poupe et une sixième est en
construction elle alimente un tiers du
pays en électricité
c'est la partie la plus importante de la
centrale où l'on trouve les turbines et
les générateurs pour nous la géothermie
c'est la meilleure énergie c'est la
moins chère on la trouve sur place elle
n'est pas dangereuse et surtout
écologique
ici en afrique où près de la moitié de
la population n'a pas accès à
l'électricité
cette énergie renouvelable est abondante
pourrait être la solution mais le kenya
comme beaucoup d'autres pays du
continent manque de moyens financiers
pour exploiter ses ressources
ici c'est la banque européenne qui a
investi plus de 270 millions d'euros
depuis près de 40 ans de l'argent qui
est prêtée et l'union européenne y
trouve aussi son propre intérêt à culoz
muller
not only ce qui nous pousse à agir ce
n'est pas seulement le réchauffement
climatique c'est aussi pour améliorer
les conditions de vie des gens vimpat
pipeau wild pourquoi c'est important
parce que l'europe fait face à de
nombreux défis malgré l'immigration en
plus la résolution des conflits 10
l'énergie ccam est alors le
développement
ces dix dernières années l'europe a
investi plus de 26 milliards d'euros en
afrique dont cinq pour le développement
des énergies propres c'est le continent
où elle investit le plus d'ici quelques
mois quand les infrastructures
tourneront à plein régime olkaria
deviendra la plus grande centrale
géothermique du monde